Okay, good morning. So, um we start the
very last section of the course today.
It's on the AngloAmerican Empire which
rules the world today. So, um we will
first look at the rise of the British
Empire. Um and to understand the rise of
the British Empire, we first need to
discuss the rise of the Spanish Empire.
So, let's go back. Um, and we discussed
that um, it was the Spanish who were the
first to colonize the new world. And
they did so because they were looking
for gold and silver. And it turned out
they found a lot of gold and silver. And
all this money was now going back to
Spain. And that became the basis of the
Spanish Empire.
And you would think it's a really good
thing that they found all this gold and
silver, but it was a disaster for the
nation. Okay? And the reason why is that
at this time in history, Spain was a
feudal
Catholic
monarchy and the all this money just
made the system even worse. So let me
explain. A feudal system means that
there are rigid
um there's a rigid hierarchy of status.
The nobles and the clergy at the very
top. And because of all this gold and
silver, the clergy and the nobility
don't actually have to pay taxes anymore
and they actually have to make no
contribution to society. All right? So
you have this, you know, this group of
parasites that are sucking up a lot of
wealth. um a lot of energy within
Spain. Okay, so that's the first
problem, this feudal system. Second is
the idea of Catholic. Um so because of
the Catholic religion, people don't
really care about what happens today.
They care about what happens when they
die. They care about making sure that
they have a place in heaven. So they get
all this money from
um the new world and none of it goes
into industry and innovation and
technology and science. All of it goes
into uh religious activities. For
example, religious festivals, churches,
masses and all this money is being
wasted on these religious festivals.
Okay. And the third thing is monarchy.
So they have a king and this king also
happens to be through marriage the king
of the Holy Roman Empire which is most
of Europe. So if you're a king you have
you have an infinite amount of money.
What do you do? Well you go on a series
of stupid pointless
wars all around Europe. And he was
fighting the Ottomans. He was fighting
um um uh the French. uh he was even
fighting the Catholic Church because he
wanted to be stronger and and have more
authority than the pope and he was
paying for these wars through with this
gold but also uh by borrowing uh and so
at the end of the 16th century Spain
even though it was at this point in
history the most powerful empire the
wealthiest empire with the largest army
it went bankrupt basically. All right.
So this system was was a disaster for
Spain. Okay. Another issue is um because
of
feudalism, the Spanish nobility thought
it was beneath them to work hard. They
believed that it was um uh contemptuous
to to exert yourself to be a noble means
to sit back and enjoy life. Okay. So
this money um was a disaster for Spain.
So um to understand what happened, just
think of an analogy. Let's just say
today I give each of you 100 million US.
You think that's a lot of money. And so
you go and you waste it all on ski
trips, on buying a new Maserati, on
buying a private plane. And then you
recognize, oh, you know what? If I keep
on doing this, I'm eventually going to
go bankrupt. So what you what do you do?
Well, you go and you invest in
businesses, right? And you recognize
that, hey, if I go to invest in
businesses, what I should do is borrow
money from the bank in order to have
greater leverage in order to make more
money. And the bank says, well, you have
$100 million, so I will give you uh
money. And so you get you take about a
billion dollars um in loans. And because
you're not a very sharp business person,
you have absolutely no business. You you
have actually no experience running a
business. Well, in 10 years time, all
your businesses go bankrupt. Okay? And
so you find yourself a billion dollars
in debt. You start you start out with
$100 million and then through reckless
expansionism, you have a billion dollars
in debt. And that's exactly what what
happened to Spain. Okay. All right.
But this system created opportunities
for those who did work hard. Okay. And
these three countries that will take
advantage of the system are
um
France,
England and Holland. Okay? Or what we
call the Dutch Republic. Okay? Uh don't
worry about the name for now. And so
there are three ways in which they took
advantage of this new system that the
Spanish created. The first is through
industry. Okay. And what this means is
um the Spanish didn't have any industry.
They were still an agricultural based
nation but they wanted textiles. They
wanted finished goods. So the French,
the English and the uh Dutch, they they
did work hard because of the religion.
they were Protestants, okay? And they
believed in in hard work and so this
created a middle class for them. All
right? So they industrialized uh because
of Spanish demand. So that's the first
way that these three countries
benefited. The second way is through
piracy. So what was happening was that
these ships were transporting all this
gold and silver from the new world back
to Spain, which means that you can just
hijack these ships and steal all their
gold and silver for yourself. and piracy
became the official policy of the
English. All right. So, um Francis Drake
was the most famous pirate of this time
and he was like an admiral in the
British Navy sponsored by the queen,
Queen Elizabeth the first and he was a
national hero because he would go and he
would steal all this gold and silver
from the Spanish and replenish the uh
the English crown. All right. So, piracy
was a really important way these three
countries made money off uh Spain. Also,
because of piracy, these three countries
were forced to innovate in their navy.
So, the system of naval warfare at this
time is like you would ram your ship um
at another ship, you would board it and
then you would uh take over that ship.
Okay? So, it's it was hand-to-hand
combat. And what the English figured out
was, you know what, we can just have
cannons on our ship and then just pound
the other ships from a distance. Okay,
basically artillery and uh long range
fighting. And that's what the English
pioneered and that's why eventually they
become over time the greatest navy in
the world. All right, so piracy was u a
very important factor in the development
of the English navy. The third thing um
is for trade.
Okay. Um, but specifically through
smuggling. So the idea is all this
territory in the new world was
controlled by the Spanish crown. And so
everyone started to smuggle in order to
avoid paying taxes and levies to the
crown. So what were they smuggling?
Well, they they were mainly smuggling
slaves. Okay. So um slaves were for most
of human history the most profitable
product that you could trade and this
was even more true at this time because
the new world had these plantations
um and they needed people to work these
plantations. So they started to
transport slaves from Africa to the new
world. Now there is a misconception
um in history that the Europeans went to
Africa, kidnapped these slaves and then
transport them to the new world. Okay,
this is not true. The reason why it's
not true is the Europeans actually did
not want to go to Africa and stay there.
And the reason why is malaria. So what's
happening was that the Europeans set up
um trading centers around Africa and it
was the Africans themselves who would
give the European slaves. And the reason
why is um these nations, these tribes in
Africa were fighting against each other.
And the custom at the time is if you
lost a war, then we would enslave the
entire um population and then sell you
to the Europeans. So, so not only were
the Europeans getting rich off this
trade, but so were many African um uh
clans and tribes. Okay. So, so, so that
is what happened. All right. Um the
other thing
is what what people misunderstand is
most of the profit was actually not in
gold and silver. Okay. At this time in
history, the most profitable product,
the thing that was most valuable is
actually spices. Things like nutmeg,
cinnamon,
peppercorn, right? These are the things
that Europeans really valued. One ship
of these things was enough to make
fortunes for entire families for
generations. All right? So, in other
words, the center of trade was not
actually in the new world, but actually
in Southeast Asia. Okay? Southeast
Asia.
Okay. So from China, the Europeans
imported silk and porcelain. And from um
the Southeast Asian islands, Indonesia
basically they imported spices. Okay. So
this became known as the East
Indies. The East Indies. And this is
where the money was to be made. Okay. So
the key to world conquest was who could
control the trade routes into the East
Indies. Okay. So the the the people
uh that first really figured this out
were the Dutch. Okay. So the Portuguese
are here, but the Portuguese are like
the Spanish. Okay, they are a Catholic
nation, but the Dutch are the ones who
figure out how to make a lot of money
out of the East Indies. All right, so
how did the Dutch how were the Dutch
able to succeed? Um, it has to do with
the fact that at at this time in
history, the Dutch were controlled by
the Spanish. Okay, the Spanish were in
charge of the Hapsburg Empire, which
included Spain. Uh, sorry, which
included the Dutch. Okay. So at this
time in history uh the Dutch are part of
something called the low countries. Low
countries include includes today the
Belgium and the Netherlands. Okay.
That's considered the low countries. And
for for the longest time the low
countries have been part of the Holy
Roman Empire. And um this system worked
well for the low countries because they
were they were poor. They didn't have
much resources. So they were left alone
by the Holy Roman Roman Empire. they
they had a lot of local autonomy. They
were very independent and very
egalitarian uh nation and everyone there
because it was cold, it was poor, people
worked hard and the low countries was
one of the first places developed
textiles and as such did they start to
trade with Spain. They became wealthier.
But over time as Spain became more and
more powerful it went to exert more
authority over the low countries.
What's happening at this time is protest
protestism is spreading all across
Europe and the king of Spain wanted to
maintain capitalism in the low countries
and this brought them to conflict with
the low with with the people in the low
countries. Okay. And this created
something called the 80 years war. It
was really a war of independence
um between um so so um there were
certain individuals certain um cities
and low countries that want independence
from Spain and of course Spain want to
maintain control this war will last for
80 years now the problem is that Spain
it is the most powerful nation in the
world at this time the low countries
it's it's it's it's like 1.5 million
people at this time okay so it's very
very small place and so they can't
possibly fight um Spain but they persist
because because they're led by religious
fanatics and over time what they realize
is even though they can't beat Spain on
land they can actually beat Spain on in
the sea. Okay. So what they recognize
is, you know what, the way to beat Spain
is if we can control the trade in the
East Indies, that's going to give us the
military, that's going to give us the
wealth and the resources to fee to
defeat Spain. But we are a small and
poor nation. So how can we best do this?
And the solution would forever change
human history.
in6002. Okay,
1602 they created something called the
Dutch
East
Indies
Company and uh it's known as VOCC in uh
Dutch. Okay, the Dutch East Indies
Company. This is really important in
human history because this is considered
the first multinational
corporation in the world.
Okay, this corporation it's not
controlled by the government but it has
the power of government. It can raise
its own military. It can create its own
laws. It can issue its own currency.
Okay. And this company will go on to
become the most profitable and most
valuable company in the whole world. If
you take
Apple, Microsoft, and Google, these
three companies, and you combine them
together, they would still not be as
wealthy as the Dutch East Indies
company. And the reason why is they had
a monopoly over trade for
spices in the East Indies. Okay. So then
the question then is why would the Dutch
do this? Why would the Dutch go out and
create their first multinational
corporation? And the answer is they
needed a way to unite the people of the
low countries into fighting the Spanish.
How do you incentivize the people into
fighting the Spanish? Most people were
indifferent. They're like, "We don't
really care. The Spanish are far away."
But you had some fanatics who wanted
independence. But you also had some
individuals who were heavily
Catholic. Okay. Eventually what will
happen is the people who want
independence will move north to the
Netherlands and the people who want to m
to remain Catholic will move south to
Belgium. Okay? That's why if you go to
Europe today, if you go to Belgium, it's
heavily heavily Catholic. But if you go
to the Netherlands, which is still uh
one of the wealthiest countries in the
world, it's actually Protestant. Okay,
that and that's what happened. Okay. So
they need to unite the people and the
best way to do that is to incentivize
them by giving them shares equity in a
company. Okay. So now people have
actually have an incent incentive to
actually fight the British because if
the Dutch East Indies company makes
money they get rich and that's what h
actually happened. The east the Dutch
East Indies company will become
extremely wealthy and and so that will
create a middle class in Holland. So the
first issue is equity. Okay. But also if
you think about it this is actually a
very clever way to raise
taxes because if you try to get taxes
from people they will rebel against you
right but if you say hey listen we have
this company and if you uh invested in
it uh you might get rich well it's it
well this is equivalent of selling war
bonds to people right so that's the idea
and that's why the Dutch East Indies
company it really marked a turning point
in the war between the Dutch and
Spain.
Also, this will allow the Dutch East
Indies Company to work hard to control
the trade in the East Indies because if
they work hard, they are the ones who
profit, not not the not the king. And
over time, what will happen is the Dutch
East Indies Company will push out the
Portuguese and they will monopolize this
entire area. And as a result um they
will become extremely wealthy. What's
important to remember and this is why
the Dutch actually don't really talk
about this history is
um a lot of brutal horror happens
because of this process. Okay? Because
they are multinational corporation only
interested in profit. They commit ethnic
cleansing. They basically wipe out the
population. They enslave people to work
in plantations to grow these spices.
They will constantly engage in a series
of wars against the Portuguese. this in
the English and the French in order to m
maintain control over the monopoly.
Okay. But over time, what they will
recognize is they don't actually have
the population resources to to maintain
their empire. So they will retreat and
leave this empire to the French and the
English, but they will still be
subcontractors to the English and the
French. And that's why the Netherlands
remains one of the wealthiest countries
in the in the world today. Okay. a lot
of their wealth is
hidden. Okay. All right. So, what's
important for us to
um understand
is this war is actually driving the
growth of the middle class and
Protestantism in Europe. All right. So,
let's let's review
um the process of religion. Okay. So
it's this actually
Calvinism. So there are actually two
major ideas that differentiate Calvinism
from Catholism. Okay. The first is the
idea of
justification by
faith. So in the Catholic religion, you
show your faith to God by doing good
works, by giving money to the church
basically. But in the coven religion,
which is what the Dutch Republic adopts,
it's justification by faith, which means
that you and
God communicate. And God knows if you
are faithful and you yourself know if
you're faithful. So if you spend money,
if you build stuff, that doesn't matter.
The works doesn't matter. What matters
is your true faith. Okay, that's the
first thing. Second thing which is more
important is the idea of
double
predestination. So remember from our
lecture on the Protestant
religion reformers are trying to destroy
the influence of the Catholic Church
because they think the pope is evil. All
right. So the main power of the Catholic
Church comes from the idea that is a
church who decides whether or not you go
to heaven and for how long. Sorry,
whether or not you go to heaven. If you
don't go to heaven then uh what then
then do you go to purgatory and for how
long? Okay. So the church has control
over your afterlife. And so what what
the Calvinists believe is no the church
doesn't because at the beginning of time
even before the world was created God
had already decided who would go to
heaven and who go to hell. Okay that's
the idea of double predestination. Your
destiny has already been
decided and only a minority called the
elect will go to heaven. Everyone else
will be damned to hell. Okay. And again
these ideas were created in order to
erode, dilute, destroy the influence and
power of the Catholic Church so that
people can be liberated um from the
church in order to celebrate God um in
the proper way. But we discussed this.
These two ideas will now create a new
problem which is how do you know if you
are party elect, right? How do you know?
Well, I believe so. I believe. But how
do you how do you really know? Okay. And
the answer they discovered is you know
through your virtuous hard work. Okay.
through
simple hard work. Okay. Um and so how do
you know if you are working hard? How do
you know that your life is simple
enough? Well, because you're
accumulating
money, right? Does that make sense?
Money now is actually useful. Before it
wasn't that useful, but now money is now
a testament to your
faith. Okay? Okay. And this marks a
radical change
in human perception in human identity.
Before we were people very much focused
on
status, right? Now we focus on
wealth. So let me explain the
difference. Okay. What does status mean?
Status just means how you are perceived
in your community. So you work hard um
in order to win approval from your
peers. So remember the Vikings, okay?
The Vikings would go on these crazy
adventures. Why? Because they would come
back and tell these stories that would
entertain and impress their peers. Okay?
Also remember the Vikings, if they have
money, what they what they would do do
is this. Remember the Viking funerals, a
third of all their wealth would go into
funeral expenses, okay? Having a big
feast for everyone. A third of their
wealth would then uh go into the funeral
clothes, dressing well for the funeral
and a third of their money would then go
on to the family members. All right? So
for most of human history, we didn't
believe it was important to have money.
What's important was to impress the
community. And that's why you make any
money, you would immediately come back
and hold a huge feast for the community,
right? And that's still true in China
today where you know you you you are um
from a village, you come to Beijing, you
open a restaurant, you make a lot of
money. What do you do? You go back to
your village and you hold a huge feast
for the villagers, right? Okay. So
that's the idea of status. And that's
what before we were concerned about. Now
we're concerned about wealth. Why?
Because wealth is a measure of your
faith. It is a testament to whether or
not you will go to heaven or not. All
right. And this marks a radical change
in human perception and this creates the
idea of class now. Okay. And the
market. All right. So, does this make
sense guys? All right. All right. So the
other issue
is now that the Dutch food trade they're
making a lot of money but at the same
time they're actually not allowed to
spend their uh money because they have
to um exemplify simple hard
work. Then how do they enjoy their
wealth? Okay. And the answer is through
art. So now you have a art market in the
first time in human history. Before art
was something that was patronized by the
wealthy. But as the middle class rose in
the Dutch Republic, now the middle class
can enjoy art. And this will mark a
radical change in uh in how art is
created. Okay. Now and also because of
this you have a new idea called
materialism.
So the accumulation of goods, if you
don't if you don't spend your money on
the community, if you don't spend your
money on the church, where do you spend
your money? You spend your money on the
house, right? On where you live. So
that's why it's important to buy silk
and porcelain from China. That's why you
want to buy spices because it's a
measure of your wealth within the
household. Okay, remember and this is
really important. This is driven by
three factors.
Okay. The first factor is anxiety.
Anxiety comes from the
fact that
um you don't know if you're faithful to
God or not. So you must prove to
yourself you are faithful. Okay. So
that's the first idea, anxiety. Second
is the idea of uncertainty.
Uncertainty means like at this time in
history the Dutch Republic is at war
with Spain. Spain again is the most
powerful empire in the world. You don't
know if you'll survive. You don't know
if um the Dutch Republic will survive
against Spain and it probably will not.
All right. But the uncertainty come also
comes from the
fact that trade is precurious. Okay.
right now you're wealthy because the
Dutch East Indies indies company is is
profitable and you you have stock in the
Dutch Dutch East Indies company but it's
also possible tomorrow um England or
France or Spain comes and whips out the
Dutch East Indies company. Okay. So
there's a lot of uncertainty in your
life. And the third thing
um is
competition because
remember only a few people will go to
heaven. But there's a lot of wealthy
people in the Dutch Republic. So how do
you prove that you're better than your
the other members of the middle class?
Well, there's going to be competition.
Okay? You have to prove that you are a
more simple, more faithful individual.
All right? And because of these three
factors, anxiety, uncertainty and
competition, it will drive three major
developments in human society, the
creation of money, uh the creation of
the art market. Okay, the art market
also includes literature by the way, but
that comes later. And the the idea of
materialism in human life. And if you
think about it, this is now becomes the
prototypical
middle
class
identity, right? And so even though
we're in China and we are not a
Christian nation, um, and we don't we've
never went through this
history, the middle class in China still
has the values and the ideas that the
Dutch had 500 years ago. Okay? Chinese,
the Chinese middle class is obsessed
with moneymaking. It's obsessed with
materialism and it's obsessed with the
accumulation of artistic objects. All
right. And so that's the history
here. All
right. Any
questions before I go into the evidence
and some of the
history. It was this clear to you guys.
Okay. I I know I'm going fast, but but
but we have to we have a lot to do. All
right. Uh in order to finish the
semester, okay, so let's go over some of
the
history. Okay. So, uh the Dutch golden
age. All right.
So 1588 is is basically
uh when uh the war between the Dutch
Republic and Spain really begins to take
off. So let's go over some basic
background about the Spanish Empire.
Okay, so remember Spain has territories
in the new world. What's important is
that Spain is not
colonizing the new world. Okay, Spain is
only interested in extracting resources,
specifically gold and silver, from the
new
world. Okay, so there's no there's no
colonization going on. There's just e
economic exploitation going on. And the
ships, the navy is designed only
to take the gold and back to Spain. And
again what this does is it creates
opportunities for piracy which the
English and the Dutch will exploit very
heavily. Okay? And these um centers of e
economic exploitation will also need a
lot of slaves. And so the English, the
French and the Dutch will take these
slaves from um Africa and smuggle them
into the plantations to feed these
colonies.
Okay. Um so this wealth allows um Spain
to enter its golden age. And one of the
main
um um artists of this golden age is
actually Magal Cervantes and he's famous
because he wrote a novel called Don
Cahotei de Lamancha and it's considered
the first great novel or or the first
novel in human history. It is an amazing
book, Donote De Laancha. I would teach I
would love to teach it to you at the
time, okay? But it's about a thousand
pages. But you know what? It's it's it's
easy to read. You can read it by
yourself. Okay? I highly I highly
recommend it. Donkea de Lancha. Okay?
But during this time, of course, you
also had great artists um and great um
um literature happening as well. This
money was being wasted in Spain. Okay?
It was being wasted in building these
wonderful beautiful buildings like El
Escaro in Madrid. It's just outside
Madrid and it took took about an entire
year of bringing back gold and silver
from the new world to build this
building. But for the longest time this
was the largest building complex in the
entire world.
Okay. Um Spanish because the Spain
because it was so wealthy became became
the fashion trends center for all of
Europe. So um Spanish dress, Spanish
clothing became popular throughout all
of Europe, especially
England. Um so what will happen is the
Spanish royal family will marry into the
Hapsburg and the Hapsburg family
controls the Holy Roman Empire and the
Habsburgs are like the most famous
dynasty in Europe at this time. they
will marry uh and then Carl Charles will
inherit both Spain as well as the Roman
uh the Holy Roman Empire which includes
the Netherlands.
Okay. And so this is his empire and as
you can see it's actually most of
Europe. This is Spain and this is the
Holy Roman Empire which includes the
Netherlands, the low countries.
The problem though is once you have this
territory, you have to defend it. And so
he comes in conflicts with all the great
powers of the day, okay, including
France, which is the peer competitor to
Spain at this time. You he will also
come come into conflict with the
Protestants under Martin Luther, okay?
He's trying to step up uh the rise of
Protestantism, especially Calvinism in
Europe. He will also come in conflict
with with the Ottomans. Um and he will
also come in conflict with the pope.
Okay. So with all this money uh the king
of Spain is causing wars with just
basically everybody and he he becomes a
bit of a bully which bankrupts the
nation. The problem with the Habsburg is
they have a terri terrible reputation
for um inbreeding. Okay? They only marry
within the family. And if you do that
over three or four generations, you get
this guy.
Okay? Uh King Charles II. And this is
what you get. So do not incest is a bad
thing. Okay? We outlaw incest for a very
good reason. And because of this, he has
no here, which causes the end of the
Spanish
Empire. All right? So the Spanish Empire
as we discussed will allow for the rise
of the Dutch Republic. The Dutch
Republic it's rising because it has very
strong industry and then it builds it
builds trade networks all around the
world. Okay. So as we discussed it
controls the Baltic trade and it and
what it does is it um basically trades
textiles across this area and then it
will capt it will trade slaves across
the Atlantic and then it will monopolize
trade in the um East Indies and that's
why um in the 17th century the Dutch
Republic will become the wealthiest
nation in the world and its middle class
will become the most prosperous and
wealthiest in the world at this time.
Okay, because all this trade. All right,
so this is a map that shows you the
extent of trade
uh in the Dutch Republic. Okay, so this
is a Spanish and as you can see most of
the trade is actually focused across the
Atlantic. All right, this is the French.
They get involved as well, but their
trade is nowhere near as dense as the
Dutch and the British. Okay. And
eventually the Dutch and the British
will come into conflict with each other
in the Anglo Dutch wars for dominance
over the
seas. And what will happen is the Dutch
will win most of these naval battles.
Okay, the Dutch are superior uh are
superior sea people, but the British are
much more persistent and the British
have a much greater population. The
British are like the Romans. Remember,
the Romans didn't didn't win that many
battles, but they just never gave up.
They were relentless, and they were
willing to make they were willing to
sacrifice most of the population in
order to eventually win. Okay, that's
just the British mentality. All right,
they weren't great at they were not as
superior as the Dutch uh at sea or
against the Spanish and the French and
um on on land battles, but they were
just much more relentless and
persistent.
Okay. All right. So let's go over the
major differences between Spain and the
Dutch Republic. Okay, how was the Dutch
Republic Republic able to rise and
defeat Spain and win its independence?
Well, the first thing is Spain was a
Catholic religion that focused on
orthodoxy. Okay, so everyone had to be
Catholic and um everyone had to obey the
power of the church. And so you may have
heard something called the Spanish
Inquisition, right? So it was the
Spanish who created the people call the
Jesuits were responsible for enforcing
orthodoxy within the Catholic world. The
Jesuits will will come to China as well
and spread the Catholic religion. Right?
The Dutch because they were smaller,
they had few people, they were forced to
be tolerant. So all these Jews that were
being expelled from Spain end up in the
Dutch Republic. And it's important that
you to have a a a group of Jews within
your nation. Why? The first reason is
they have these trading networks. Okay,
remember there's a Jewish diaspora and
the Jews have these trading networks all
across the world, especially within the
Ottoman uh empire. Okay, that's the
first reason, trade. Second is
uh finances. Okay, so historically Jews
have these financial networks all across
Europe. And so if you need a lot of
money to start a war, well, you all you
you often go to Jewish financers. Okay.
The third is intellectual. Um the the
Jewish people are extremely open-minded,
extremely intellectual. They bring in
new ideas. So one of the most famous
intellectuals at this time is named
Barack Spinosa. Okay? And he's he's he's
Jewish. All right? Uh but it was not
just um Jews. Everyone was allowed to
practice a religion in the Dutch
Republic freely. And that was one of the
main drawing points about the Dutch
Republic. Okay, the tolerance. This is
important because the Dutch Republic
will become the model for the American
Republic.
Right. Second difference is Spain was a
empire focused entirely on economic
exploitation. They were only concerned
about extracting resources whereas the
Dutch was just focused on mercantile
trade. Okay, this is important because
if all you do is focus on exploitation
um this will lead to mismanagement and
this will lead to a lot of wealth
inequality and that was the issue facing
Spain. Okay. But if you but you focus on
mercantile trade then you can create a
middle class which is what happened in
the Dutch Republic. The third major
difference of course is uh noble and
clerical privilege. So only the elite
benefited from the Spanish Empire
whereas the Dutch Republic because they
were small um they had to focus on
middle class growth on making sure that
as many people as possible benefited
from uh trade and commerce. Okay, it was
really trade and commerce that allowed
the Dutch Republic became wealth so
wealthy over time. And because the Dutch
Republic um it's very small and the land
isn't great, they uh as the Dutch
Republic became more wealthy, they focus
a lot of the resources on building
canals and on uh land land reclamation
from the sea. Okay. And so um and so as
time as time progressed their land
increased. All right. So another really
important thing to remember about the
Dutch Republic is that is a coalition is
a federation of different citystates.
Okay. There's seven um different places
within the Dutch Republic. Okay, that's
why it's a republic and not a monarchy
because a lot of their decision-m has to
go through um cons consultation and
diplomacy. Now this is also why they
created the Dutch East Indies company
because the fear was that if they didn't
have a monopoly a company to control the
monopoly then if different city states
would open would compete against each
other for the East Indies trade and they
didn't have the resources to do to do
that that that's why they combine the
resources to create the east uh the
Dutch East uh Indies company.
Okay. Okay. Um what's important to first
remember is that throughout its history
the low countries uh the Netherlands
they are they were an egalitarian
independent and open-minded people and
so some of the most famous philosophers
were coming from this region including
Arasmus who um is contemporary of Martin
Luther uh and who was one of the main
consider one of the great philosophers
and theologians. Okay, he's he's he's
he's primarily responsible for something
called the Northern
Renaissance. Uh Arasmus will allow for
the rise of Spinosa. Okay. And again,
he's formerly um Jewish, but then he
becomes he creates a new religion called
pantheism. You may have heard, you might
have heard about pantheism, but
pantheism is the idea that God is within
every living being, including trees,
including animals, including us. and
therefore we're all connected through
the essence of God.
Okay. Um let's talk about art. Okay. So
I I want to focus the rest of the
lecture on art because art will give us
a um a portal into the mindset and
psychology of the Dutch people. But
before we do that, let's let's talk
about Spanish art. Okay. So this is a
Spanish um golden age and a lot of this
money is going into patronizing great
art. And as you can see, Spanish art,
it's very Catholic. So if it's Catholic,
then it's very allegorical. So they're
drawing they're drawing uh images from
the Bible and from the Catholic
tradition. Um and it's a worship of um
the religion. Okay. So this is Madonna
the Mary and this is baby Jesus. As you
can see, everyone's worshiping uh Jesus.
The problems are iconoc class which is
they don't they do not they do not allow
for depictions of their god in uh im
imagery.
Okay. Um this is another great artwork
from the Spanish golden age. As you can
see it's heavily um allegorical. Okay.
Metaphorical. All right.
Um this is the most famous painting of
the Spanish golden age by a painter
named Diego uh Vatacquz. Okay, you
probably have heard of him. He's he's
one of the most famous painters in the
world. This is his most famous painting
called Last Menades the Handmaids. Okay,
what's amazing about this painting
is that we are
actually as we are observing the
painting this painting is actually
observing us as well. Okay, does that
make sense? Because this is a painter,
right? So the painter is looking at us
as we're looking at him. Now
um what he's really who who he's really
drawing um is the royal couple. Okay, as
this mirror shows, but as you can see,
we are also within the universe of this
painting. Okay, I I mean there's a lot
to say about this painting. It's it's
it's the most famous paintings in the
world. All right, but but I but I but
we'll but we we have a lot to do today,
so I'll move on. Um these are landscape
paintings and as you can see there's a
lot of spirituality, a lot of
allegory, a lot of divinity embedded
within these paintings. All right. So
this is a Catholic
mentality. All right. So now let's move
on to the Calvinist Dutch mentality of
paintings. All right. Um so let's do a
compare and contrast. This is the Dutch
this is a Dutch painting. This is a
Catholic Spanish No, sorry. This is
actually an Italian Renaissance painting
by Karajio. Okay. And this is baby Jesus
and Madonna. And there are two
individuals
uh who supplicants who are worshiping
Madonna. Right? So this is the Catholic
mentality which which is God can be with
us at any time. Right? So this is the
Dutch equivalent where um this is a
middle-ass woman and these are two
street mi musicians who are
um trying to interact with this world.
Okay. What's really important for us to
understand is with the rise of the
middle class there's a huge focus
on hierarchy and boundaries. Why?
because the middle class itself is a
very fluid, very flexible, very an
uncertain group of people. Okay? So
their paintings will reflect this
anxiety and this uncertainty. All right?
So as you can see the inner world, it's
full of light. The out the outer world
it is pretty dark. And this this door is
a portal. Okay? Within the house
um there's this divinity. But in the
outside world there's only darkness and
mystery. Okay. So God is within your
household basically. All right. So
there's a lot more more uh to be said
but as you can see there's a huge
contrast between the Catholic mentality
and the Calvinist mentality. All right.
Let's move
on.
Um so still life is a very important
aspect of Dutch painting.
Dutch um still life it is a encaps it
captures the material world as it is.
It's a celebration of material world
because remember the Catholic celebrate
the out the afterlife but the Calvinists
the Protestants celebrate the the here
and now. Okay. They do that through
depictions of the um of of life in in
the household. Okay. And and what will
happen is this. At first,
um the Dutch Republic is at war and it's
very poor because all this money is
being is going into the military. But
when the war ends, when the Spanish
actually conceded independence to the
Dutch, you can see the wealth for
everyone increases dramatically. Okay?
And once there's peace established, then
the Dutch will become the wealthiest
nation in the world. and and arguably
okay arguably even today the Dutch are
still the wealthiest middle class in the
world but a lot of their wealth is
hidden
okay all right um because the Dutch are
communist they feel that life is a
struggle between their
urges and their faith okay so in this
painting depicts that um this man who's
fat he represents festival he who
represents giving into your urges,
eating, drinking, being merry and this
person is called Lent who which is the
Christian virtue of fasting and showing
uh restraint, showing temperance. Okay,
so the Dutch see life as a constant
struggle between your urges and your
faith, between your emotions and reason.
Okay, and this picture depicts that. And
so what what paintings are doing is it's
taking all this internal anxiety within
you as a person because of your faith
and it's transposing it projecting it on
to
uh the painting in order to create a
visual visual depiction of your anxiety
as to relieve your anxiety. Okay, that
does that logic make sense to you guys?
And that's and that's and that's what
drives the need or the desire the demand
for middle class art during uh the 17th
century. It's it's only about 100 years
right from 1600 1700 in the Dutch
Republic. And we're only talking about
between one and two million people 5 to
10 million paintings will be sold. Okay.
5 to 10 million paintings will be sold.
That's that's the um that gives you a
sense of the appetite for the sort of
visual
depiction.
Um one thing that obsesses the Dutch
middle class are the poor. Okay. Why?
Because the middle class they are an
anxious uncertain group of people. So
the way they define themselves is
um they try to differentiate themselves
from other other groups of people
including the poor and the nobility.
Okay. So in their in their in their
imagination the poor are just gives give
themselves up to temptation. Okay.
They're drinking all the time. They're
getting drunk. They're they're they're
they're lazy. Okay. All right. Does that
make sense?
And by depicting the poor in this way,
it's almost like like a talisman to
protect themselves from being
poor. You know, it it it's really taboo.
You know, the worst thing that can
happen to us is if we become poor people
like these people because we'll end up
drunks. Um prostitution is also a very
um popular theme among um the Dutch
middle class. So what's interesting is
prostitution at this time it's very
popular in the Dutch Republic and hey if
you go to the Amsterdam today it's still
popular right um it's Amsterdam is sort
of famous for the legalization of of
prostitutes so at this time what was
happening is you have all these
prostitutes but good middle class women
were responsible for going and
negotiating with them in order to
satisfy their husbands. Okay, does that
make sense? So this is so the idea of
prostitution it is a huge topic
um in the Netherlands and it's a cause
of a lot of anxiety and uncertainty
um and desire within the middle class.
All
right. Um another depiction of poor
people. Okay. So I can as you can see
they're having fun all the time. And if
you focus on these two individuals, this
man who's who clearly has these sexual
urges, he's trying to slowly take this
maiden who's resisting but really can't
resist into his world, right? And so
this is saying like if you ever become
poor, you just cannot resist the
temptations and the urges of this world.
So the worst thing that can ever happen
to you is if you become
poor. Um another depiction of what it
means to be poor. Okay. To surrender
yourself to luxury and to the
moment. Um this is a still life. And so
the idea of here is one of access. Okay.
And so um the psychology here it's it's
it's very interesting. All right. But
but let let me give you an analogy.
Let's just say that you are trying to
lose weight. Okay. You're kind of fat.
You are or you're not you're not fat but
you feel um you could lose weight,
right? So when you're trying to cut back
on food, you have all these temptations.
You have all these desires. So one way
one strategy that you have is if you
watch a lot of videos where fat people
are binging on food okay just by
watching these people your sort of
anxiety your sort of desire decreases
and that's the strategy of these
paintings where you have these paintings
of access and wealth and just by
observing these paintings by by putting
up these paintings in your household
they become signals to you that you
should you should not engage in any
excessive activity.
You should lead lead a life of
moderation and temperance. Okay. Another
picture of uh a prostitute, a poor
person. Okay. So, you have all these
paintings about the life of the poor.
And what's really interesting is yes,
um it's obvious we don't be poor, but
these paintings are also very seductive,
right? They're trying to show you, oh,
you know what? It's actually pretty
nice, a lot of fun to be poor as well.
And and that's what the judgmental class
really enjoy. They like they like to
enjoy this anxiety between not having
something because you because it's bad
for you and wanting it.
Okay. Um this is a very famous painting
called the precursor. Okay. So remember
in this within this world it's very
common for middle- class women to go
solicit prostitutes for their husbands
and the middleman is some is someone
called the picarus okay and she looks
satanic right so this is an image that
is supposed to uh represent sexual
desire but as you can see there's very
there's some demonic qualities to it
okay you can see sort of like the
evil eyes and laughter after of the
people
involved. Does that make sense to you
guys? Um, this is Yanstein, one of most
famous painters of this
time. Okay. So, so as you can see, there
are a lot of paintings that follow these
themes. At the same time, you have also
depictions of what it means to be a good
middle class household. Okay? So, as you
can see, these paintings are ones of
simplicity, ones of restraint, ones of
temperance, ones of prudence. Okay? So,
within these paintings captures a lot of
middle class Christian
values. All right.
Uh this this is another
representation. All right. So you can
see the
simple Calvinist work ethic being
depicted in this
picture. Uh this is Rembrandt who is the
most famous painter from this par from
this period. Okay. Rembrandt.
This is probably the
prototypical portrait of a wealthy
person in the Dutch Republic. Okay,
she's wealthy, but the most important
thing is for you to understand, she's
simple, right? She's not luxurious and
decadent like the Spanish are. She is
very restrained. She's very focused.
She's very temperate in her behavior.
Okay? So she represents the
quintessential wealthy middle class uh
woman. All
right. All right. So now let's just
discuss
why the Dutch are buying these
paintings. Okay. The question then is
why is why is there an art market?
What's the purpose of an art market? And
so there are different reasons. Okay.
Well, the first major reason is to show
that you're refined. Okay. to engage in
beauty to show you have taste. Okay,
that's the first reason. Um, second
reason is because of the Cal Calvinist
religion, the money not now no longer
goes to churches. Okay, churches are
meant to be simple. If you go into a
Catholic church, it's luxurious. It's
golden. But if you go into a Calvinist
church, it's very simple. All right? So
now people are transferring their wealth
from the temple into the household in
order to better worship God. All right?
So a lot of these paintings are
religious in nature because they're
trying to turn the houses house houses
houses into churches. All right. That's
second reason. The third reason is the
idea of con conspicuous consumption.
Conspicuous consumption to enjoy your
wealth and to show your wealth off to
your neighbors. All right? So when you
invite people off to dinner parties,
they can they can see how wonderful your
artwork is. U nostalgia is you
are thinking about classical Greece,
classical Rome. Now and another reason
is meditation. Okay. And so we talked
about this where the middle class um
they're always afraid of becoming poor.
Okay. Um, so what they do is they freeze
their anxiety, competition, and
uncertainty in a contemplative hole.
Okay? They take their anxiety and they
project it onto the painting in order to
better meditate on the idea of what it
means to be middle class. Okay? Does
that make sense? But there are also
three more reasons which are more
important for us. These three reasons
are the representation of the other
taboos and boundaries. Okay. So as we
can see um the paintings of the poor
represent the poor as lazy, excessive
and violent. Okay, always giving into
their sexual urges. And so they're
trying to create the idea of the other.
Okay, the poor are the other that we
must at all times
avoid. Second reason is transference.
Okay. So you have all these desires to
eat good food, to engage in sex that you
cannot do because of your religion,
right? So you transfer these feelings
onto the artwork itself. So the artwork
itself becomes the subject of your
desire. Does that make sense guys? All
right, that's second major reason. The
third major reason is just simply
hypocrisy. All right, the artwork is a
shield. It's an armor. It's a dress for
you to show that you have good
values. All right, so these are the
three more nefarious reasons why dark
becomes popular. And guess what, guys?
They're still true today. All right,
these are still the reasons what drives
culture today, including literature, uh,
movies, okay, artwork. Okay, and so in
every age you Sorry, sorry. Um, so let's
let's now just summarize what we've
learned. Okay, so the Italian
Renaissance, you have great artwork from
the Italian Renaissance, you have great
artwork from the go the Dutch Golden
Age. Okay, what what are the three
differences? Well, the first major
difference is the Italian Renaissance,
it's patronized by the wealthy people.
All right? And as such, they're trying
to have nostalgia for the past. That's
why a lot of the paintings are of
classical Greek and Roman uh individuals
and his historical and and history and
the art is meant to be celebrated by the
community. Okay, that's why they're hung
up in churches or public places or in
the Vatican. Okay, does that doesn't
make sense? That that's the main idea of
Italian restaurants. When we get to the
Dutch golden age, um it's pigeonized
mainly by the middle class who are
interested in depicting the present in
the here and now. And they're only
interested in their individual
contemplation with the art. Okay? Their
individual communication and dialogue
with the art itself. And this will give
rise to the modern art market.
Right? Any questions before I move on?
All
right. So to summarize, art is a
response to the anxiety, uncertainty,
and competitiveness of middle class
life. Okay? It's still true today. Art
encapsulates the alienation of the
individual. And that's still true today,
right? That's what art
is.
Um, this is happening because there are
certain pathologies to middle class
life. uh that's still true today. All
right. The first pathology is middle
class
identity demands the control and
regulation of yourself and other people.
All right. But why? Because you are you
have a fear of
disorder. Right? So so we we discussed
this where middle class life is
competitive, it's anxious, it's
uncertain, right? So this creates
pathologies within you. And how do these
pathologies express themselves? Well,
through a fear of disorder, but you also
have a fear of germs, okay? Cleanliness,
right? The middle class is obsessed with
cleanliness. That's why the middle
class, if you if you just mentioned the
idea of infectious diseases, okay,
germs, they just run away. Okay? They're
really afraid of the idea of infectious
diseases. Now, last is um sorry, sorry,
I sorry, is a fear of loss. Okay. Sorry,
I um this is wrong. Okay. to be fear of
loss. So, uh the middle class is also
consu obsessed with accumulation
achievement. Okay? And if you think
think about it,
okay, this explains why Chinese parents
are so obsessed with getting their kids
into good universities, right? The Ivy
League, because of regulation of
yourself, cleanliness, and accumulation
achievement.
So there's no logical reason why your
kid must get into Ivy League. All right?
You can't explain to me through pure
analysis, pure reason, pure logic why
it's important to get your kid into Ivy
League. It doesn't really benefit you or
the the kid. In fact, I personally
believe that um getting Ivy League will
actually hurt and hamper your life
chances for success. Okay. But if you
think about the pathology of the middle
class, what it means to be middle class,
the fact that they're uncertain and
anxious and getting them created IV
League is a way to relieve their
anxiety, okay? Their OCD, then it makes
sense. Okay. All
right. All right. So now I will conclude
by talking about who I think is the
greatest artist of the Dutch Golden Age.
His name is Johan Vermeier. Okay. In
every age um in every movement you will
emerge a great artist who subverts the
movement okay who shows you the
pathologies the problems the ironies the
paradoxes within this movement okay so
what Johan Verier is really good at
doing in his artwork is demonstrating to
us the
hypocrisy of middle class life right so
this is one of his most famous paintings
called View from the dev guys. This was
paint painted about 1650. I have no idea
how he did this. No one has any idea how
he did this. The lighting is perfect.
Okay, it's like he had a camera like
like an iPhone and he snapped a picture
of his city. It's perfect. The lighting
is absolutely perfect. How was he able
to do
this? All right. And so my only my only
explanation, okay, and again it's my
theory
is what makes great artists different is
they're able to dissolve their ego.
They're able to dissolve their body and
their soul becomes part of the moment.
Okay, does that make sense? So in other
words, what Verimeir did is he became
the painting itself. The painting became
him and then he became the painting. And
what he's doing right now, he is just
expressing his soul.
Okay, so that's my theory. All right,
this is his most famous painting. Okay,
I'm sure you guys have seen this girl
with the um pearl area, right? This is a
beautiful painting, but I will show you
some problems or some ironies in this
painting.
Obviously, this pearl earring is a
problem because she's an ordinary
person, right? She's maybe a maid. She's
a young person. She's poor. Why would
she have an a pearl earring which is
extremely precious, extremely valuable,
extremely expensive? Okay, that's a
question. That's the paradox
or mystery within this painting. Then
this gives this leads to the question
um why is she looking at us seductively
right? She's looking at us with like
desire with yearning and then you
recognize well she probably has a master
a patriot right? She's probably working
in a household and maybe there's a
relationship of sorts between the maid
and the husband. Okay. And so it's a
story, it's a novel that draws in your
imagination, but more importantly, it
shows you the
hypocrisy within middle class life.
Because the entire purpose of
prostitutes is so that the husband would
not do this crap at home, right? Because
it's important to maintain the sanctity
of the middle class household. It's your
temple of worship. So you're not allowed
to to seduce your servants. Okay? So
this is extremely
subversive painting that at the same
time seduces us. It almost begs us to do
do the same thing. Okay? It's trying to
demonstrate our own sexual deprevity and
our own sexual
desires. Okay? It shows us the
relationship between sex and power. Does
that make sense,
guys?
Right. Uh this is the milkmaid. Okay.
Another really famous painting. Uh
again, and I have no idea how he does,
but the lighting is perfect, right? The
lighting is absolutely perfect. Not only
that, but the lighting is able to
highlight the
blemishes of the wall, right? So, he
could have just made the wall white, but
instead he's showing us the cracks, the
blemishes within the wall, which is a
metaphor for the blemishes and the
cracks within middle class boures life.
All right. Now, when you first look at
it, you think, "Oh, this is a picture of
middle class, simplicity, and hard work,
right? She's a
virtuous, faithful young woman who's
hearty, uh, who's dedicated to her
work." Okay? But then you focus on this,
right? And there's sexual qualities to
this, which is the center of the
picture. It's almost like she's peeing
or
this I mean use your imagination. Okay,
do you understand? Right. So within this
wholesome picture is embedded a picture
of sexual
possibilities. Does that make sense
guys?
Okay. And the idea here is it's meant to
be subversive. It's it's meant to make
you uncomfortable, right? You guys laugh
a bit, but but but if you're a middle
class person, you have this painting in
in your house, you're a bit disturbed by
what you see. All
right. All right. Another really famous
painting by Vir. Okay. Interesting is we
are sneaking in, right? We are looking
in. We're spying into the scene. And
that's what and what Vamir is saying is
that's what the middle class do. The
middle class are afraid of
participating, but they love
spying, right? They love peering. They
love peeking into the taboo and the
forbidden. That's that that's why we
have art to peer into the forbidden.
Okay? And as you can
see, the painter and the model, there's
a bit of a sexual energy between the
two. Okay? And that's what excites us.
That's that's why we're sneaking that
that's why we are peeking into this
scene. Okay? We're hiding ourselves
behind the curtain and we're trying to
capture the sexual possibilities between
the
two. Okay? Doesn't make sense,
guys. Um so these ideas that middle
class life, um it's inherently flawed.
There are blemishes, their cracks be uh
behind the veneer. It's fundamentally
hypocritical. It gets captured in
literature later on. Um first in Madame
Bovery. Okay. And then most famously the
most famous novel of all time, Anna
Karina, right? That middle class life,
it's fun fundamentally hypocritical. So
on the surface it seems you know
Anacarina uh she married a very faithful
very loving husband and then she
betrayed him to mar and and had this
affair that destroys entire families. Um
on the surface it shows
you the importance of maintain
maintaining the sanctity of middle class
life of maintaining rules and order
because if you don't do so it will lead
to disaster and heartbreak. Okay. But at
the same time, you read this novel very
closely. It's about a thousand pages. By
the way, it also shows you the hypocrisy
of middle class life. How Anakrina
herself has been oppressed by the taboos
and the boundaries set upon her by the
world that she lives in. All right. And
that's and that and this is what's going
to drive literature from now on. Right?
Okay. That's it. Okay. So, next class we
will we will do the rise of England. All
right. But it's important that we
remember that the British Empire, a lot
of the ideas of the British Empire are
now being seated in the Dutch Republic,
including the idea of multinational
corporations, including the idea of
capitalism, including the idea of middle
class life. Okay. Including the idea of
artwork and literature. Okay, any
questions about today?
Okay. So, uh next class we will do the
rest of England.